a one-two-three test test test if you're
going to do videos about numbers
these are the ones you would love to do
as far as the computer is concerned this
simply doesn't exist don't ask me to say
it we could be here till next week 16th
of very session on its way it's my
actual favorite number so this is called
a truncated icosahedron it's five sided
pentagon let's try it out I'm going to
try and play this as well you'll notice
the difference I just realized that
there is a number that I see every day
when I enter my office and this number
is 42 and well if you need to go to the
toilet you get up and you have to move
past all the other people I'm in the
southeast corner of England today and
talking to you about a number with bit
of a difference it is an antique 1980s
television
[Music]
they get to figured they get to 20 sheep
and they couldn't cope with that yeah
thanks for pointing that out thanks for
bringing that up
and as a child I was fascinated by this
absolutely fascinated but it's taken me
15 years to get to the point where I can
explain it to you